when
is the only herrero activist in germany
100 years since the end of german
colonialism the 71 year old namibian is
calling for the german government
to take responsibility we're just
demanding three things
an apology recognition of genocide and
reparations
if you break something you have to fix
it
it was here in berlin that the fate of
africa was decided at the 1885 berlin
conference
the continent was sliced up and divided
among european
powers prior to world war one
germany had colonies around the world
after losing the war german overseas
land was then redistributed
and later decolonized
millions were affected by the brutality
and greed of german colonialism
an attempt to exterminate the herrero
and nama people in german south west
africa
today namibia resulted in the murder of
at least 80
000 people out of fears of costly
reparations
german parliament has never officially
recognized the murders as genocide
but the government has promised a
thorough assessment of the country's
colonial history
we are of course holding reconciliation
talks with namibia right now
we're trying to formulate what happened
100 years ago or more
so that we as europeans can apologize
for the terrible things there
and take responsibility
[Music]
but also so that this is accepted by the
african side
so that our future is not because we
talk about the past
but what we can do together now
but for israel talks excluding herrera
and nama people
count for nothing some activists have
gone as far as filing a lawsuit in new
york against the german government
calling for their participation
the return however of some 20 herrero
and nama human remains at a ceremony in
berlin's french church
is being regarded as at least a step in
the right direction
issued as positive i think this is
positive what isn't good is that it's
taking place in a church
why not in parliament and then recognize
the genocide at the same time
like many herrera and narma activists
israel wants all plundered artwork and
human remains to be returned to their
home country
the german government however favors
more provenance research
by museums but israel isn't about to
give up
like most of his fellow activists his
campaign for germany to recognize the
murders of herrera and nama people as
genocide
is a personal one i also have german
ancestors
that means that my history has something
to do with germany
and i tell you now i will fight until i
die